Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ich bin Dr.
Östensäu und ich bin der
diestabende Arzt in dieser Stelle
und heute werde ich das an einem Gespräch
mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstander?
Ja, gerne.
So erst war ich ein paar personelle Dachhänd.
Deswegen werde ich ein paar Fragen
über die Frage stellen.
Wie heißt es Ihnen?
Mein Name ist Andreas Kunze.
Andreas Kunze.
Nein, Kunze.
Könnten Sie langsam das hier dazwischen?
Mein Name ist Andreas Anton Nordpol,
Doran Richard, Emil Anton Siegfrieds.
Nachnamen ist Kunze, KWK,
KWK,
UNZE,
Ulrich Nordpol,
Zorro, weiß ich nicht, Emil.
Kunze.
Okay, Herr Kunze, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 29 Jahre alt.
29 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß.
Und wie viele wiegen Sie?
82 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Ich habe aktuell keinen Hausarzt.
Ich bin umgezogen
und war jetzt nicht krank gewesen.
Okay, das ist wichtig, aber Sie müssen so weit
einen Hausarzt anbinden.
Ja, aber...
Und was?
Ich bin nicht krank geworden, da wollte ich nicht um einzugehen.
Okay, es passiert.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Student.
Student.
Studiere ich?
Was sind Sie genau geboren, könnten Sie mir sagen?
Ich bin am 16.07.1995 geworden.
1900?
1995.
Okay, Herr Kunze,
was ist Ihre Hauptbeschwerte?
Was fühlten Sie so uns?
Ja, ich habe heute mit meinen Freunden Fußfall gespielt.
Und ich bin mit dem rechten Fuß umgeknickt
und habe mir den Sprunggelenk verlenzt.
Sprunggelenk?
Ja, ich habe Schwellung und Schmerzen
in meinem Fuß umgelenkt
und ich kann nicht mehr richtig auftreten.
Ich muss umpülen.
Okay, ihr habt das verstanden.
Das ist das, das ich lief, das ist für uns.
Und so könnt ihr mir sagen,
haben Sie eine Bewegung, eine Schwingung auch?
Ja, ich kann nicht mehr abrollen.
Sie können nicht auf den Fuß kommen.
Nein, abrollen meine ich.
Also ich kann nicht richtig abrollen,
heißt ich kann nicht richtig meinen Fuß nach vorne.
Also Bewegern so.
Okay, ja, das schon.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Wie ist es, es ist kranfartig dumm oder stängend?
Ja, irgendwie, ich würde sagen,
stechen der Schmerz
und ein pulsieren der Schmerz.
Das pocht.
Pochen der Schmerz.
Okay, wie ist die Umfeld passiert?
Haben Sie selbst das gemacht
oder haben Sie mit jemandem angestoßen?
Nein, es war keine Fremdeinwirkung.
Es war selbst, also ich wollte trippeln
und beim trippeln ist mir der Fuß umgeknickt sozusagen.
Okay, dann wie stark Ihre Schmerzen,
könnten Sie mir auch eine Skala,
das das Schmerzen ist,
eines und stärkste Schmerzen,
bewerben?
Dann würde ich sagen so sieben.
Sieben.
Gibt es ein bestimmter Auslöser,
oder ist nach der Faktur Ihre Schmerzen?
Noch mal eine?
Das ist ein bestimmter Auslöser, oder er bleibt der Faktur.
Er bleibt der Faktur.
Er sagt noch, bestimmter Auslöser.
Was genau so, ich bin mit umgeknickt.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie,
wo Ihre Fussbewegen in diesem Fall Ihre Schmerzen
stärker sind oder nicht.
Wenn Sie sich verlasten, nehmen Sie Schmerzen zu.
Bei Belastung.
Sie haben dieses Schmerz.
Wie?
In der Ruhe haben Sie auch dieses Schmerz.
Absolut, in der Ruhe.
Entschuldigung, ich habe das nicht richtig ausgehört.
In der Ruhe habe ich leichte Schmerzen.
Okay, dann haben Sie außer Schwellung
eine Farbeveränderung
und eine andere Symptome.
Nein, also Farbeveränderung sehe ich nicht,
aber es ist deutlich geschwollt.
Es ist deutlich geschwollt.
Haben Sie eine
Unterstutzung,
Materialgenutz oder nur Haben Sie ihre Ruhe?
Also, wie ich hierher gekommen bin,
meinen Sie?
Wie eine Schiene oder die andere Sache?
Nein, ich habe keine Schiene.
Ich habe versucht, normal zu laufen
und es wurde immer schlimmer.
Strahlen die Schmerzen
irgendwo hin aus?
Ja, ich meine,
ich meine, Fußstrahlen die aus.
Man sieht, wie ich mich belaste.
Und
jetzt würde ich ein paar Fragen
wie Ihre Zustands stellen.
Haben Sie
andere Probleme, z.B.
Herzrasen, Herzkloppen oder Husten?
Nein, habe ich kein Problem damit.
Okay, dann haben Sie Probleme
beim Wasserlassen, beim Stuttgart?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Darf ich fragen, warum fragen Sie das?
Ich komme wegen Fuß und Sie fragen, ob ich
Wasserlassen Probleme habe?
Diese Fragen sind routemäßig
und ich muss diese Fragen an Sie stimmen.
Deswegen mache ich dieses Prozess.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie Apetitlosigkeit?
Nein.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie Apodazu genannt?
Ich würde sagen,
es ist gleich geblieben.
Zuerst habe ich ein paar Fragen über Ihre
Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie irgendeine chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen, was meinen Sie dann nicht?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob Sie eine Medikamente bekommen müssen.
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Sie eine Medikamente bekommen müssen.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Beide bedanken Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe bedanken,
ich habe ab und zu mal 400 Millikamern zu Hause.
Ich habe noch nicht eingenommen heute.
Ich war noch nicht zu Hause.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich wurde am Blindamm operiert vor 15 Jahren.
Vor 15 Jahren?
Ja.
War die Operation kompliziert?
Nein, die OP war kompliziert zusammen.
Ich hatte während, oder bin dazu zugezwungen,
dass ich nach der OP allergischen Reaktion gehabt habe,
wegen dem Antibiotikum, das Sie mir gegeben haben.
Die OP war okay, aber...
Ich kann Sie mit der Weite gehen.
Noch mal.
Also, ja, die OP selber war kompliziert.
Aber weil ich Antibiotika damals bekommen habe,
hatte ich eine allergische Reaktion gehabt.
Erinnern Sie, was heißt dieses Antibiotikum?
Ja, das Pendicilin.
Wie oisert sich die Allergie?
Das war so, dass ich schlecht atmen konnte.
Also, ich hatte Atemprobleme, Atemnot.
Außer, dass es noch ein Hautausflug oder Örtem?
Genau, ein Hautausflug hatte ich auch im Oberkörper.
Ob es irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, ich hatte das.
Ich hatte das.
Umverträglichkeiten? Nein.
Nicht als Früste.
Okay.
Ich würde ein paar Fragen über Ihre Gewohnheit stimmen.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Putuzer?
Ja.
Was rauchen Sie?
Zigaretten.
Und viel, viel, viel.
Und seit 5 Jahren?
Seit 5 Jahren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol? Nein.
Bitte diese Frage nehmen Sie nicht bei so einer.
Das ist eine ultimäßige Frage und ich muss an Sie stellen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Kontakte mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Kontakt nein.
Okay, Herr Putuzer.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen an Sie abhängen von Ihrem
Familienzustand.
Sind Ihre Eltern am Neben? Ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Krone erkrankungen?
Krone, Erkrankungen.
Ich weiß, mein Vater nimmt irgendein Medikament wegen seinem Hutruck.
Gibt es sonst etwas?
Mein Vater, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ihre Mutter hat irgendwelche krone Erkrankungen?
Krone, glaube ich nicht.
Aber bei ihr wurde die rechte Brust entfernt.
Sie hatte einen Tumor.
Vor 3 Jahren entfernt.
Vor 3 Jahren.
Es ist sehr wichtig, dass Sie sich anrufen.
Ich hoffe, es geht besser für Ihre Mutter.
Seit 3 Jahren geht es regelmäßig zu Kontrollen.
Das war auch noch fertig gewesen.
Das ist wunderschön.
Sie sind Studenten.
Haben Sie Probleme?
Haben Sie Stress beim Erkrankungen?
Text- und Text-Erkrankungen habe ich nicht.
Arbeiten Sie?
Ja, nebenbei als Student arbeite ich am Frühstück.
Am Flughafen, beim Check-in.
Haben Sie Spaß mit der Arbeit?
Ja, manchmal schon.
Sind Sie Lady oder verheiratet?
Ich bin Lady.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Familie?
Nein, ich bin allein zu studieren.
Ich bin hier nach Frankfurt gekommen.
Ich habe alle wichtige Informationen, die ich benötige,
an Sie gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas in Suche gehen?
Nein, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Was habe ich denn gemacht?
Ich würde Sie untersehen.
Dann müssen wir unbedingt 2 Ebenen
an X-ray rennen können.
Beim Fußgelenken.
Dann werden wir die Situation bewerten.
Ich muss mit meinem Oberast
Iris Justant sprechen
und dann mit einem bestimmten
Diagnose.
Ich habe gesagt, da wird X-ray rennen.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Was ist das?
Das ist ein mildgebendes Verfahren.
Das ist sehr schnell und schmerzlos.
Ist es gesundheitsschädigend?
Leider, es ist ein bisschen gesundheitsschädigend.
Aber die Dosierung ist nicht so hoch.
Es wird nicht ein bestimmtes Problem
für den ersten Mal.
Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe gesagt, es wird nicht so hoch.
Aber es wird bis zum ersten Mal.
Für den ersten Mal? Was kann passieren?
Wir werden dieses Verfahren
vielenmals durchgeführt.
In diesem Fall, es könnte,
ich kann es sagen,
es könnte Ihnen sehr gerne beschädigen.
Und die
Wenn ich das nicht will, dann kann ich das machen.
Okay.
Wie ist das Risiko?
Das ist wahrscheinlich...
Das ist sehr wenig.
Sehr wenig?
Sehr sehr wenig.
Sehr gut.
Gut.
Danke.
Danke schön.
Eine gute, einem lesge ich für unsere Kollegen.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe mich immer nicht.
Deutsch bitte.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie in Fuß eine krippelne Prellung oder eine Deformite?
Eine Deformierung, höchstens, dass es nur stark beschwollen ist.
Ansonsten eine Deformierung sehe ich nicht.
Eine krippelne oder eine sauberte Gefühl?
Können Sie Ihre Finger sichern?
Finger oder Bewegen?
Finger oder...
Finger habe ich in der Hand, in der Fuß habe ich siehen.
Bewegen oder?
Ich kann meine Zehe oder meinen Vorfuß bewegen.
Eine Frage?
Ja, bitte.
Sind Sie Ihren Fuß nach innen oder nach außen umgeknickt?
Nach außen umgeknickt.
Okay.
Die andere Frage, sind Sie nach dem Erreignis hingefallen?
Oder wurden Sie in anderen Bereichen verletzt?
Nein, ich bin nicht hingefallen.
Das war nur ein Unknicktraum.
Ich bin nicht auf den Boden nachgefangen.
Vielen Dank.
Gut.
Aber gute Frage.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Wo ist die genaues Schmessen im Innenbereich der Gelenke oder außenbereich?
Am Außenbereich, am Außenknöschel.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie an Ihren Fuß Gelenk Knerschen bemerkt?
Knerschen bemerkt.
Kann ich nichts sagen?
Okay, danke.
Am Spungelenk, ja.
Nur eine Frage.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Was ist das für eine Schmessen?
Ich habe schon mal eine Frage.
Vor ca. 10 Jahren hatte ich auch noch eine Verletzung.
Ich habe auch ein Krankenhaus.
Die sagten damals, dass ich eine Außenbahn-Zerumkette hatte.
Das war auch beim Fußballspiel.
Ich habe eine Frage gestartet.
Können wir als Haskell-Chipri anfangen?
Ja, der Kollege weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin nicht sehr abweichsinnig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Sturzion gibt.
Okay, dann guten Tag Herr Oberatz.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Es geht um Herr Kurze.
Er ist 29-jähriger Patient.
Er ist 78 cm groß.
Er ist 82 kg.
Er ist Student.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns wegen einer Schwellung.
Er hat auch in dieser Berei eine Schwellung und Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen seien auf einer Skala 7 von 10.
Er hat auch eine Bewegung.
Er könnte nicht ihre Mischung gelenkt.
Er hat eine Stattung von Extensionen, Abtüchsen, Addyksen.
Er hat keine Verkaufung.
Er könnte ihre Stattung bewegen.
Er ist unaufwertig.
Er kann keine Verkaufung nehmen.
Herr Kurze, können Sie die Patiente vorstellen?
Ich? Ja.
Ich bin der Herr Ustenscheu.
Wenn ich das vorstellen würde, würde ich sagen,
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich bin neu hier in der Klinik.
Ich würde gerne ein Patient bei Ihnen vorstellen.
Er hat heute beim Fußball spielen einen Distorsionstrauma mit
dem rechten Sprunggelenk erlitten.
Er hat eine deutliche Schwellung über den Außengnöschel.
Die durchsputte, die pärrefäre durchsputte Motoregesensibilität ist intakt.
Er hat belastungsabhängige Schmerzen.
Er kann beim Laufen den Fuß nicht mehr abrollen durch Schmerzen.
Ich habe den Verdacht, dass er entweder eine Außenband-Ruptur
oder eine Außengnöschelfraktur hat.
Typ W bar B oder A. Das ist meine Verdachtsiagnose.
Deswegen habe ich den Patienten zur Radiologie geschickt.
Da habe ich einen Röntgenveranlass,
der sich in zwei Ebenen durchzuführen.
Der Verdacht hat sich bestätigt, dass er eine Außengnöschelfraktur hat.
Ich habe ihn mit einer RK Schiene versorgt.
Ich habe auch empfohlen, dass er kühlen,
schonen und hochlagern soll.
Die weiteren Untersuchungen,
die er bei den niedergelassenen Projekten durchführen soll.
Danke schön.
Das war die Wunderschöne.
Ich habe das mit der Kommandtredakt.
Die allergie-Ibres-Oysert-Sicht
und der Überblick.
Das ist der Überblick.
Er hat einen Überblick.
Das ist ein Überblick.
Die Überblick.
Nein.
Das ist ein Überblick.
Exantem, exantem, exantem, exantem.
Das ist Oberkörpers, ja.
Er ist ja auch ein Halbepakunkprotok, seit fünf Jahren.
Er trinkt nicht.
Bekürzt, in der FSB müssen wir peckjürs sagen.
Peckjürs, okay. Das bedeutet 2,5 Beckjürs.
Und Alkohol, Konsum und Alkohol, Konsum und Dragan, Objus oder Ferneit.
Im Faminellen Alamneze hat Fatel Hazard, Hyper Tony und Mutel Hazard hat Mamakrebs.
und seine Mutter wurde vor drei Jahren wegen Mama Krebs operiert.
Und die Mama...
Ja genau, wenn die Mama entfernt wurde, wie würde man das nennen?
Zustand nach...
...Momekthomie.
Ich habe gerade...
Ich habe es nicht gehört, akustische Entschuldigung.
Zustand ist die Mama...
Ja, nicht das. Zustand nach, was?
Ich habe nur Akustische Entschuldigung gehört, sonst nicht.
Mama-Kathomie, Mama-Kathomie.
Mama-Kathomie hab ich nicht gesagt, aber...
Ja, Masterkathomie.
Ah, okay, okay, Masterkathomie.
Mama-Kathomie.
Bei Mama-Kathomie, genau.
Zustand nach Masterkathomie, rechts, bei Mama, CA, vor drei Jahren.
Ja, genau.
Er ist ledig, er hat keine Kinder, er lebt online.
Und so ist...
Was ist, was ich wollte sagen?
Er dacht, um den differenzialen Diagnose.
Also, was wäre die Diagnose?
Also, was kann man auf jeden Fall...
Wir haben ja noch keinen Röntgen gemacht,
die waren wir ja veranlasst.
Aber, was kann man sagen, auf jeden Fall,
was die Diagnose ist?
Nicht Verdachtdiagnose, sondern die Diagnose ist...
Die Diagnose ist eine Distortion,
Gelenkdistortion,
oder wir können Trauma sagen,
ich denke.
Genau, Distortionstrauma.
Distortionstrauma des rechten Sprunggelenkes.
Oder des Fußes, kann man auch sagen.
Hier würde man,
vorhin hat eine Kollegin drauf hingewiesen,
wie ist dieser Umfallmechanismus gewesen?
Es ist ja nach außen umgeknickt.
Also könnte man sagen,
was ist das für eine Distortionstrauma?
Ein Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Ein Subfinationstrauma, kann man auch sagen.
Subfination.
Pro Nation, Subfination.
Kann man auch sagen.
Also, letztendlich ganz grob,
haben Sie recht, Sie haben gesagt,
ein Distortionstrauma des Sprunggelenkes,
das auf jeden Fall die Diagnose ist,
ist ja eine Distortion gewesen.
Mit Verdacht auf was?
Was ist hier Verdacht?
Mein Verdachtdiagnose ist da eine Sprunggelenkbandriss.
Ein Außenbandriss,
weil es ja lateral passiert ist,
diese Schwellung ist lateral.
Außenbandriss,
weil er die selbe
Unfallvorher gehabt habe.
Das ist ein Bevorworter für unsere Diagnose.
Und aus der Diagnose könnte es ein Sprunggelenkfaktor.
Beispiel?
Was noch?
Auf ein...
Was hat er vor 10 Jahren gehabt?
Hat er ein Außenbandzährung gehabt?
Also, es könnte immer noch eine erneute Außenbandzährung sein.
Also, keine Lektur, keine Fraktur,
sondern auch eine Zährung des Außenbandes.
Kann auch sein.
Okay.
Wie geht es weiter?
Ich würde den Patienten Körper unterzuholen,
danach würde ich einen Zugang einlegen
und gleichzeitig Blut abnehmen
für die girmung Paramedes oder eine Operation...
Operation im Wahlbedarf könnte durchgeführt werden.
Die girmung Paramedes-Kleinbildung
um zu leben und zu üben
um die Brauchern während dieser Operation zu werden.
Und aus der Zeit,
wir müssen nur ein, 2 Ebene
Schmuckengelenkfröten fernlassen.
Und...
Die sind alles für mich.
Also eine...
Genau, es gibt...
Wie würde die genaue Aufnahmeanweisung sein?
Also, was würden Sie haben wollen?
Wie heißt es genau?
Weil es gibt ja...
Im Sprunggelenk gibt es einen oberen und einen unteren Sprunggelenk.
Das heißt, wenn Sie eine Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen,
würden Sie sagen, ich möchte eine Röntgen...
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt in 2 Ebenen haben.
BoESG, also oberen Sprunggelenk.
Okay, ich kenne nicht die Anleger.
Deswegen sind Sie ja als Stetsarzt, kein Problem,
es wird alles gelernt.
Sie sind ja neu auf diese Abteilung in der Unfallsteroge.
Sie müssen nicht sagen, wenn Sie alles wissen,
dann werden Sie schon verratzt.
Danke schön.
Kein Problem.
Also Röntgen, OSG, also obere Sprunggelenk
in 2 Ebenen, würden Sie veranlassen.
Was ist, wenn Sie...
Haben Sie den Begriff gehört Weberfrakturen,
kennen Sie sich damit aus?
Weber, tip, tip, tip, tip, tip.
Genau, kennen Sie damit aus, also der Herr Kohlepflege?
Leider, keine Ahnung.
Kein Problem. Es gibt A, B und C.
Man tut die Einteile im Röntgen.
Wenn da Sprunggelenk da ist
und auf Höhe der Sündosmose,
wenn der Bruch weiter unten ist,
Listal ist, ist es eine Weber-A-Fraktur.
Die muss man nicht immer gleich operieren.
Es kommt auch an, wie die Stellung ist
und wo genau das Geburten ist.
Weber-B-Fraktur meistens wird operiert,
weil es dann ein bisschen Instabilität eventuell da ist oder nicht.
Das hängt davon ab, wie genau das,
wie die Klinik und wie genau der Bruch verlauf ist.
Und Weber-C-Fraktur ist meistens eine OP-Intecation.
Da muss man das schon operieren.
Okay, also das heißt,
Sie haben geröntcht und wir gehen davon aus,
dass er keine Fraktur hat.
Wer hat dort eine deutliche Schwellung?
Wie würden Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Ich würde eine Analyse und eine Analyse verschreiben.
Ein Was?
Eine Analyse.
Eine Analyse verschreiben.
Außerdem würde ich eine Bandage empfehlen.
Oder eine Schiene empfehlen.
Außerdem würde ich empfehlen,
dass die Patienten seine Fuß hochlegen.
Und auch eine Stück.
Also Gehhilfen, genau.
Wenn er nicht belassen kann,
unterarm Gehhilfen.
Man kann dann ein Unterarm Gehhilfe geben.
Wenn wir eine Unterarm Gehhilfe geben,
meistens, was können die dann nicht richtig belasten?
Was muss man dann noch aufachten,
wenn jemand mit unterarm Gehstützen läuft?
Ich weiß nicht.
Was denkt man, wenn einer nicht in seinem Fuß belastet?
Was ist das Gefahr?
Was ist das Risiko, wenn er nicht belasten kann?
Es hat mit dem Blut zu tun.
Herr Kollege, vorher haben Sie gesagt,
Pech.
Vorher haben Sie schon vielmal gesagt,
Pech bei der Therapie.
Pech?
Müssen Sie mir helfen, was weinen Sie mit Pech?
Pause, Eis, Kompression, Hochlag.
Hoch, ja.
Pechschonung.
Kenne ich leider jetzt nichts.
Es ist einfach das Standard immer,
dass man kühlen schon hochlagern.
Muss man an Trombose denken.
Das Risiko ist dann erhöht.
Um das Risiko zu minimieren,
was würde man geben?
Apparien.
Tromboseproflachse.
Man kann nicht immer sagen,
aber man kann grob sagen,
jemand, der eine Unterarm Gehstütze hat,
sollte auch immer eine Tromboseproflachse bekommen.
Einmal täglich.
Also ganz grob gesagt.
Es gibt Ausnahmen.
Was empfehlen Sie auch noch?
Eine Verlaufskontrolle bei den niedergelasteten Kollegen.
Warum?
Meistens ist es so,
dass die Untersuchung sehr eingeschränkt ist,
weil er sehr stark Schmerzen hat.
Man kann die Bänder nicht genau 100% untersuchen.
Das heißt, die Verlaufskontrolle in einer Woche
oder drei Tagen oder innerhalb der eine Woche,
das führt dazu, dass die Schmerzen weniger werden.
Meistens.
Dann kann man besser gucken, ob dieser Aus- und Band gerissen ist.
Ob das stabil ist.
Wenn das stabil ist, braucht er die R-Cas-Schiene,
die Sie verschrieben haben, zum Beispiel nicht.
Dann kann man dann sagen,
das reicht, wenn er Volterinsalven,
also anti-inflammatorische Salmverbände, anlegt.
Man muss die R-Cas-Schiene nicht weiter tragen.
Bis zum Beweis des Gegenteils
muss er die Schiene tragen, weil man denkt,
wenn ein Außenband nicht so geschwollenes,
kann es zu einer Außenbanddruckdruck-Tour kommen.
Wie können Sie sicherstellen,
dass die Außenband alles okay wäre?
Was kann man machen,
um das eindeutig zu untersuchen?
Welche bildgebende Verfahren können Sie machen,
um den Außenband sichern auszuschließen,
dass er gerissen ist?
Für die GWB.
Um den MRT zu finden.
Nicht unbedingt, aber man kann einen MRT durchführen,
um sehr sicher auszuschließen.
Wenn einer sagt, ich will ganz genau wissen,
was ich nächste Woche im Urlaub fliege
und ich möchte in Afrika sehen
und ich will wissen, ob es gerissen ist.
Dann kann man sagen, okay,
dann macht man einen MRT
und dann weiß man, ob es gerissen ist.
Oder ob weitere Fälle zu ihnen auch sind.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Was für eine Stellung?
Feststellen.
Fehlstellung.
Fehlstellung ist eine nicht anatomische Stellung.
Sind das Mose?
Das Spurunggelenk hat eine Fibula
und eine Tibia.
Und den Talos.
Das sind die drei Partner für dieses Gelenk.
Es gibt Außenbänder.
Es gibt Innenbänder.
Tibia ist medial.
Und zwischen Tibia und Fibula
gibt es noch mal ein Band.
Das sind die Sindos.
Das ist das Band zwischen Distale, Fibula und Tibia.
Danke schön.
Herr Mehm, ich habe eine Frage.
Wie kann man sagen,
eine 1-mal-Löhr-Fractur auf Deutsch?
Auf Deutsch.
Auf Deutsch würde man sagen.
Eine 1-mal-Löhr-Fractur?
Ja, zum Beispiel, ja.
Ich würde sagen, Innen- und Außenknechtelbruch.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde das so umschreiben.
Bei Vorliegen eines kommunierten Bruchs, des Innen- und des Außenknechtelbruchs,
spricht man von einer 1-mal-Löhr-Fractur.
Ja.
Innen- und Außenknechtelbruch.
Ich würde auch umschreiben.
Habt Ihr Kollegen noch andere Fragen?